moi j'aimerais déjà que cette affaire
soit pas terminée comme ça ça se fait
vraiment pas
ce jour-là j'aurais pu mourir il y avait
plusieurs recettes je me suis fait
frapper j'ai résisté j'avais pas mal de
blessures j'ai tout camouflé j'ai tout
j'ai fait un maximum pour être bien
j'arrive pas vraiment j'arrive pas cette
vidéo ne veut pas sortir de ma tête
cette affaire ne peut pas se terminer
comme ça s'il faut que je vais jusqu'au
bout ça va prendre 5 ans mais je vais
prendre ces 50 de ma vie je vais pas les
laisser comme ça les 10 mails je vais
les retrouver j'espère que la justice
qui vont les retrouver je ne veux pas
qu'il y en a deux sur le groupe
j'espère moi j'espère deux choses
j'espère que toi tu vas aller mieux tu
vas pouvoir avancer